- Welcome back. We're here
with Shania Twain. Beep!
(audience cheering)
I love, I love how you play Pac-man.
You're competitive!
- Oh my gosh. I love Pac-man.
- I do too. But we had
one in your dressing room!
There was one in your dressing room!
Did you not see it?
- I am doing that on-
- There's a- Okay.
- Yes.
- There's a Pac-man in there.
- Oh, I just love it.
I just hate the stick
that sticks. You know?
(Kelly laughs)
- You're the person that
blames it on the game.
I love it!
- No, I'm telling you
that one did!
- Totally! I'm just kidding!
(Kelly laughs)
I'm just kidding.
It probably did, Shania.
- Wait 'til my brain sticks
and I have to play this game. Oh no.
- I'm that person, too.
- All right.
- I'm like, it's the game.
Shania's new album is
called "Queen of Me."
And to celebrate its release tomorrow,
it is time for a game called,
"Which Queen Do You Mean?"
(fanfare music)
♪ Which queen do you mean ♪
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Look at your face! Your face!
I couldn't do it! I couldn't finish it!
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god!
Please keep it just like this (laughing).
Let's call up a host.
Lord, are you here always? Like always?
Are you here?
(celestial music)
- [God] I am here, Kelly.
How you doing girl?
- I'm doing great.
- I like that song.
♪ Which queen do you mean ♪
That was good stuff right there.
- It was great, Josh.
- [God] I'm good. I'm just
walking around naked up here.
I walk around naked all the time.
I'm trinity years old,
- Exactly!
you know?
- Exactly.
- [God] I'm comfortable with myself
But I'm excited 'cause
Shania Twain is here.
She's a queen of me.
You're the queen of me.
(audience cheering)
And speaking of queens,
we got a game here today and
I'm gonna give you a clue
that will lead to a famous queen.
That's what we're talking about today.
- Oh, like royalty?
- That's right.
Now all you gotta do is
hit your button first
and give me the name of the queen.
But if you're wrong,
the other person will
have a chance to steal.
- Oh I'm...
- [God] So watch yourself.
And just to make things interesting,
we're gonna play for a
prize from our sponsor,
Netspend.
- All right.
- [God] Our good friends at Netspend.
If Shania wins,
everyone on the left side of
the audience will get a prize.
(audience cheering)
And if Kelly wins, it goes
to everybody on the right.
(audience cheering)
- I wouldn't get that
excited, right side. Okay.
- [God] All right. The pressure's on.
- Oh!
- [God] Before she was "The
Equalizer," she was Mama in-
(button beeps)
- Oh my god. Queen Latifah!
I was like what-
- It is Queen Latifah.
- I just said blank.
(bell dings)
- You got it.
- Oh, I know this kinda queen!
Okay. Okay.
- [God] You got one on the board.
Okay, now here's the next one now.
- Oh Shania, I'm feeling it.
- [God] She was all like,
"Off with her head!"
when Alice-
(button beeps)
- Queen of Hearts!
(bell dings)
- [God] It is the Queen of Hearts.
(audience cheering)
- Why are you so fast?
Okay, I'm gonna, okay.
I will not tell my
strategy on the next one.
- [Kelly] Okay, go ahead. Go ahead.
- [God] Okay. Alright. Okay, here we go.
This is it now. Shania's
gonna come back now.
- Okay.
- She's gonna come back now.
Here we go.
- Okay.
At her passing last September,
she was the longest
(button beeps) reigning-
- I am so quick.
- That's okay. You are.
(audience laughing)
- Queen Elizabeth. (laughs)
- The what?
- Queen Elizabeth. The what?
(audience cheers)
The great! She's awesome.
- [God] Which Queen Elizabeth
are we talking about?
- Queen Elizabeth the second.
- Ah.
(bell dings)
- Oh, it was the second!
(audience cheering)
- [God] I'll give it to you.
- I don't live in the UK!
- [God] We got ourselves a game here.
Come on now.
Kelly, you got three points.
- I knew it.
- Shania.
You don't have any points.
That don't impress me much.
(audience laughs and groans)
- I don't blame you.
- [God] I'm just playing.
I'm just playing.
You still the one.
- That's okay.
- You still the one.
- [God] Okay, here we go.
Here's the next question.
(Kelly laughing)
Okay. Abba sang about
this (button beeps) queen.
- I know this one.
- Dancing Queen.
- Yes. Dancing.
(bell dings)
- [God] There you go!
I knew you could do it.
It is the Dancing Queen.
- Okay.
- And you on the board.
Here's your next one.
This queen has won 12
Emmys and there's nothing
he enjoys more than a good drag race.
(button beeps)
- What, oh!
- RuPaul!
- Yep. Yeah.
(bell dings)
- It's RuPaul. You know!
(audience cheering)
- I was like, what? Then I got it.
- [God] That's what I'm talking
about. Shania coming back.
That's what I'd like to see.
Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [God] Whitney Houston
sang about this queen-
(button beeps)
- "Queen of the Night!"
(bell dings)
- It is "Queen of the Night."
- Damn, girl.
- Love that song.
In fairness, I've covered that.
(laughs) I love that song.
- [God] You competitive as hell, damn!
- I know, I know.
- Okay, damn.
- As hell! He's God.
- Calm down out there.
- Hell. (laughs)
- That's right. I'm sorry. Oh!
I'm, oops.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, here's the next question.
Let's switch things up here.
Now I want you to go ahead and name for me
one member of the band
(button beeps) "Queen."
- Oh. Oh, I know one.
- Freddie Mercury.
- Yeah. That's the one.
(bell dings)
- [God] It is Freddie Mercury.
(audience cheering)
- There's only one band.
- I know their songs.
- [God] That's right.
Now I'm gonna get a little
historical on you here now.
- Oh good. I didn't tell
what the first one...
- [God] This Queen of France
was famous for saying,
"Let them eat cake."
(button beeps)
- Marie Antoinette.
(bell dings)
- It was Marie Antoinette!
(audience cheering)
- And I love cake.
(Kelly laughs)
(horn blares)
- [God] Oh and that means it's
time for the last question.
And this is gonna be
worth 40 points. Why not?
- Oh, sure!
- Sure. Why not?
Here's your final one.
In this Eddie Murphy movie,
he flew from Zamunda to find his queen
- Oh, I know this!
in Queens.
(button beeps)
- It's "Coming to America."
(bell dings)
- Yes!
- It is "Coming to America."
(audience cheering)
- No!
(horn blares)
- [God] That's our game.
- Okay, so the prize is
a good one today, y'all,
and everyone's getting it
so you don't have to worry.
Netspend's All Access
Mobile Account helps people
manage their money and they
empower people to achieve
their financial dreams by offering
access to innovative financial
services, which is awesome.
And today, Netspend is giving
everyone in the audience $300!
(audience cheering)
Shania's album, everybody, "Queen of Me,"
drops tomorrow and the
tour kicks off April 28th.